and we are here ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the show it is the corona
cast Tim Dylan Ben Avery our producer
braving the new reality here from the
studio broadcasting this is it you know
I I don't always want to be right but
sometimes I'm right I said that that
music in America would be sooner rather
than later just a large bulbous ass that
would shake then Liz Oh went and
famously performed in front of a large
shaking ass this is true I said a lot of
other predictions that were right Ike
yeah I can't I'm mad I can't think of
what they are now but there was a few of
them there was actually a few of them
there was one that was recent was after
the Lizza one where I predicted it
people like [ __ ] it's exactly what you
said oh you said ah uh eventually the
biggest stand-up is going to be someone
dancing around on tick-tock with just
like jingles and jangles like he's not
even saying anything yes that's the
biggest stand-up video on tick-tock
right right well that was one of them I
said a lot of things I don't I have a
great track record okay and I said last
week I believe that the only economic
activities left will be what I'm doing
right now and the double penetration
seen from requiem for a dream those are
the two options you have to earn money
right now or posts mates no matter what
happens forever there will be post mates
thank God
someone with a mask will hand you a
Pokeball through a door or a slot and
they will scurry away into the darkness
forever and ever no matter if the
Yellowstone supervolcano goes off and
ash blocks out the Sun there will be
creatures that adapt in that environment
meant to glow and deliver post mates
it's just the one constant we have in
America hopefully we don't know what's
going on this is something that's very
interesting
I watched everybody become a conspiracy
theorist over the last two years maybe
even more than that I watched it happen
on the right I watched it happen on the
left I watched normies people that had
never given the Kennedy assassination a
second thought that it never read books
like the Franklin scandal I watched them
go hard into conspiracies
i watch people on the left go hard into
intrigue espionage trying to figure out
the Russia gate issue I've watched it
and I've watched it be done recklessly
sloppily as you would imagine people do
when their minds melt that's what
happens after you spend an entire
lifetime in the mainstream and you're
just you know eating tomato soup with
grilled cheese and you're just out there
trying to go to college or get your kids
into college where's a fun spot for a
vacation what kind of dog is good with
the kids we have a decent sized yard
it's nothing crazy he'll have some space
but you know how much I take like you go
from that you go from that to Epstein
overnight your mind melts it's true you
go from that to waking up that your
leaders are no good
worse than you thought bad in ways you
can barely comprehend unimaginable
overnight that happens what how can I
get mad at you how can I get mad at
these queueing on people even though
many of them are I believe to be
functionally [ __ ] and I mean you
know unfortunate people how can I get
that mad at them when they're forced to
adapt to to this new world where the
conclusions you come to or show black
pilling so empty that you are forced to
concoct stories in your head about what
is really happening and just like I
watched that I watched people last week
become Preppers I watched people become
n timers over the last week and a half
people that had nothing but positive
things to say are now changing their
tune and I've you know I kid around and
saying that we've been preparing for
this type of thing for a long time but I
mean look this is the set we are the
broadcaster's at the end of the world I
am the anchorman at the end of the world
it's not Ted Koppel it's me it's not the
guy he went on NBC could barely make
sense anymore Tom Brokaw went on NBC he
could barely speak no it's me
I'm the anchorman at the end of the
world that doesn't make me happy it
doesn't please me but it doesn't shock
me either
I'm not surprised by it I'm not
surprised they corrupt oligarchy of
clowns didn't anticipate and or bungled
the response to a pandemic this is what
happens when you erect a society run by
sociopaths who don't care as Kurt
Vonnegut said they get too
where they go you know they get to the
places they said to those positions of
power because they don't care what
happens next just go do it do it do that
do this do that do that they don't
contemplate they don't sit back they're
not thoughtful contemplative people
they're doers not thinkers so when
you're a doer it all works until it
doesn't
you know Trump is great in boom times
he's you know an eighties political
cartoon money's being made things are
good now it's a little bleak he doesn't
look great he looks like he might ever
touch a corona we are recording this
Friday everything's changing so much by
the hour yeah that I want to I want to
let you know we're recording this Friday
because I don't know I I heard New York
City was gonna be in quarantine by now
it still may happen we all got that text
from somebody everybody's got a friend
is highly placed in the government by
the way during the pandemic nobody can
get you a [ __ ] parking pass nobody
can help you at all when it's not a
pandemic
now one human being can do anything for
you they have no they can't get you a
reservation at a restaurant they can't
help you at all
but at the end of the world everybody's
got a highly placed source in the
government that's delivering terrible
news and they want you to hear first and
I heard that they were gonna quarantine
New York City seems like it's an
adventure allottee that certain areas
are gonna get quarantined then you know
BuzzFeed had that thing
quoting the NYPD saying that's all fake
it's not gonna happen
there's no plans which great either get
out of it too like there's no plans at
this time at this time is a great way to
say anything you know at this time no
plans to shut down roads what you little
quarantine would be shutting down the in
or out whether they get people to stay
in their house or they you know I mean
after the Boston Marathon bombing they
shut down Boston he told people to stay
in their homes okay until they caught
the terrorists we're not gonna go into
that but that's you know
now we're thinking about you know Drudge
Report today headline nationwide shut
down being talked about what does that
mean what does that look like how do you
shut down a country of 350 million
people how do you keep all of those
people in their homes there's a lot of
people and a lot of guns I'm not even
saying it's it might not be necessary on
some level you you have to stop the
transmission of this thing you have to
curb the transmission unless we're all
gonna be [ __ ] if you look at Italy you
look at these other countries you know
we're following the same path they are
our healthcare infrastructure by the way
not that much better than Italy you know
I know that but we're America no we have
more people and many of our systems are
as unprepared or maybe even more
unprepared than they're there you know
then there are in other parts of the
world so I wouldn't take any false
confidence don't you know in the idea
that we are a first world country well
we are in some respects and a lot of
respects but you know we're gonna put
that to the test also you know yeah you
know it's also like P of the conspiracy
people going they don't believe in the
virus that doesn't seem helpful but it
is interesting you know I do understand
because their minds have been melted
over the past couple of years and you're
dealing with candle wax minds you know
broken brains um you know I do
understand whose the government's like
well we can't test yeah
if you feel symptoms don't go to the
hospital don't get tested you start
going is this happening is this real are
we gonna go to [ __ ] the hospitals see
a bunch of nurses playing cards what's
the deal what do you mean don't get
tested if you have symptoms what's that
mean we don't have any [ __ ] tests
that's not good it's a problem I
understand it like well you're you're
not
acceptable to it da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da
I was the first comic to cancel my shows
I've chosen 2021 cancelled right now I
cancelled the tour after the cancel your
family tour I cannot believe I was
watching people debating there's people
doing shows tonight where DC improv zany
that shut it down shut it down some of
these people I know for a fact I've
money yeah they have money and they have
mansions go home you sick narcissists do
you really need approval from from
people that badly that you're willing to
go home and kill your grandmother cuz
you couldn't walk out of [ __ ] Zanies
is that where we're at now you're
willing to risk coughing on an old
person on the train and killing them
because you want to get some chuckles up
and Winnipeg shut it down please it's a
moral issue I understand if you broke a
lot of comics out they're broke and they
got to get every dollar I get it I get
it I'm not I'm not going at you know if
you have to work if you choose to work
it is with it if you have the money to
not work right now as a comic don't
[ __ ] work don't bring your fans out
people were angry at me for cancelling
Caroline's in a few other dates I'm
cancelled too early April
listen [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] ain't worth
comedy I love comedy it's how I live my
life it's the the greatest thing I do is
get up and perform in front of people
but I could take some [ __ ] time off
if the result of me doing what I like to
do kills people you see see if me doing
what I want to do kills people
then I'll take
either take some time Podcast make a
video I don't know what to tell you but
I love how reticent people were to
cancel they were like well I don't am I
supposed to not I people paid to see me
they paid to see me and get killed I was
first I called my agent last week I said
let's get let's take it out nobody's
even talking about coronavirus I was
like just cancel cancel cancel you by
next 2021 take a big take a red pen in
the big acts out acts done who these
[ __ ] that need to work what's wrong
with you it's a sick day times a
thousand what kind of cuck are you
showing up to the office they told us we
don't have to show up to the office we
can go home jerk-off a tea SpaghettiOs
do that
it's that ruining everybody's fun you
[ __ ] wacko I get it if you need to
work if you don't have any money's gonna
get bad economically out there tip
people tip the postmates speak there's
people are gonna get [ __ ] and then
they're gonna come for you if you're
less [ __ ] keep the guns keep the bars
on the windows I'm telling you I hope
I'm wrong but it's probably gonna get
hairy and it's probably gonna get tough
anything could get out of a city get out
of the city I can't I gotta be here
broadcasting during the end of the world
but if you can get out get out go to
some ranch in my time I don't know I
can't tell you how to live and if you're
young and you have immunity or you had
it you got over it this is the [ __ ]
time to travel the world [ __ ] get out
there get out there take advantage of
cheap flights go eat that Wu hen bat
sandwich go spit the strangers mouth
you're young you
take it I wish I was young I'm 35 and
yes I'm in great shape and I do
triathlons but there's other people that
aren't and I don't want to put them at
risk but if I was 22 and in the shape I
never was I would be really rocking out
I would be jetting all over this globe
[ __ ] yeah
let me out of [ __ ] college and I'm
sorry I know it's very hard listen it's
I I my senior year of high school was
great was one of the funnest years of my
life I was nominated for homecoming king
I was extremely popular everybody loved
me blah blah blah that being said I know
that there's a lot of people now that
their senior year of high school or
college has been cut short whether some
of them are athletes and they can't play
their season their last season some of
them that might have been tapped into
skullenbones and now that's not
happening I'm very sorry and I know it's
very tough and a lot of the cross
players aren't gonna get to play and a
lot of people aren't gonna get to go to
the prom but I I I say this and I say
this shut up
Italy's burning there are countries in
the world right now when they're
choosing who lives and who dies so sit
down with your privileged little
lacrosse rapists you've raised and sit
him down and say Tommy listen I know
you're upset that you can't play but let
me show you the country of Italy
remember when we went there two years
ago it's burning to the ground now
because they didn't follow these rules
so there are people that have worse
problems than you you little prick
you're gonna grow up and be fine you're
gonna grow up and be fine and you'll
remember this pandemic and you can tell
your kids how tough it was that you
didn't get to play your last season of
lacrosse which is a fake sport anyway
that doesn't go anywhere
there's no professional lacrosse I mean
there's a few of teams in Long Island
like the Long Island lizards and stuff
like that but I mean that at that point
just I mean I would rather my kid get
Wuan and check the [ __ ] out not be in
the Long Island lizards
let's get some statistics go to Drudge
Report where the headlines out right now
this is again Friday 7:20 Pacific time
in Los Angeles California
all right we're at The Drudge Report
here we go
you want some headlines headlines right
now the the top headlines it's an
emergency
in red yeah Trump to be tested complete
shutdown on table modern life turns
surreal so here's that's so that yeah so
that's the interesting thing they're
using these words now like complete
shutdown today was national emergency he
had the press conference day but they're
using these words complete shutdown now
what does that mean click that let's see
if they elaborate on what a complete
shutdown looks like because I think it
it might be the grounding of domestic
travel it might be checkpoints it might
be quarantine it might be stay in your
home it might be all non-essential
businesses will be closed I'm wondering
what that entails and what it looks like
in a country as big as ours so this is a
white house coronavirus expert dr.
Anthony Fauci yeah well he's the he's
the you know we everybody else has a Jew
we have a [ __ ]
we got a garlic knot we have a [ __ ]
meatball giving us instructions here
thank God can we get a Jew please you
[ __ ] morons yeah doctor foul Qi hey
are you throwing you know like yo
coronavirus like don't put your head
over the meatball pot cuz then you
droplets from your nose fall into the
pot then everybody gets sick how did we
get this goon Jesus Christ but so foul a
they asked him a question they said
listen is a complete shutdown on the
table I think he said anything's on the
table right yeah it's pretty vague very
vague well yeah there's there's no
explanation for what complete shutdown
mean how many deaths we got what do we
got what do we got death wise what do we
got case wise New York City's leading
the cases right now so we got more than
two thousand people in the US with the
virus and 43 have died as of right now
more than that hmm we get a lot more
than that I've been coughing I don't
know what the [ __ ] I have they tell me
that I can't go anywhere and get tested
but I just had strapped I came off of
strapped maybe I got a little sinus
infection during strep I don't have a
fever so that seems to be the real thing
is the fever if you're really if you're
really hot if you're really hot then you
got it you know but I'm self isolating
anyway I'm quarantined there's nowhere
to go is nothing to do mmm it's raining
here it's raining in LA it's depressing
the Comedy Store shut down The Improv
shut down there's still clubs in New
York happening what's going on over
there
do you people have a death wish I know
many of you were destitute
in New York City but God God it's really
kind of gross to not realize the gravity
of the situation
and I mean unless everyone is wrong
within a week or two we'll all be
looking back at the businesses that kind
of stayed open uh and we'll be like what
the [ __ ] was that yeah you know maybe
not I hope not maybe again I would like
to be wrong about all this [ __ ] I would
like to be wrong but I don't know
there's gonna be a lot of pressure to
speak to friends and family in the
coming days and weeks I'd like my
audience to fight it and stay positive
there's no reason to make amends with
people reach out there's no reason to
build those bridges it's fake if you had
to wait till a pandemic to call someone
you don't want to talk to him enough
stop hey man how are you so like this is
crazy
hang up go into the darkness let it
become you unless you can get a little
money out of them get a little change
nothing wrong with grease in the wheel a
little bit nothing wrong with throwing a
guilt play for a little capital that's
what I say give them some you know I am
I there are comics that are that are
still out there man
god bless them but I just think
right now if you cannot work if you
cannot participate in getting people
together in a room just don't just don't
do it you know where how many cases is
New York City have right now New York
seems to be a hot spot I mean New York
City I love it but it's a petri dish of
germs the subways the surfaces forget it
it's climbed over 400 today there's over
four over just today or not all together
it's for over 400 no total over 400 yeah
we're gonna have a problem in New York
City they're gonna have an issue and I
don't see how it gets resolved without a
quarantine I don't know if they're gonna
be able to keep people in their houses
though I don't know how they're gonna do
that but I guess they're gonna try all
these PT and I was in Bristol Farms
yesterday I'm standing there next to
Tyler the Creator because it's you know
I live right on the edge of Beverly
Hills and and in the Hollywood Hills and
you know people are Bristol Farms you
know the rich are going to stockpiling
crab legs in case it's the end mm-hmm
they're getting their almond milk the
free-range chicken and I'm just watching
everybody you know buy all the food and
it's like there's gonna be food folks I
think there's gonna be food I could be
wrong pavilions closed a lot of a lot of
stores closed but they'll be food I
think there's gonna be post mates I
think they're gonna stay open I think
those restaurants gonna stay open
strictly to make and deliver food
they're gonna make millions of dollars
you're gonna make a mint they're gonna
make a [ __ ] mint right now why would
you not just employ a chef or two to
cook food and send it out we do have a
you know we have been looking at some of
these crazy projections where they're
like you know 70 or 150 million people
end up getting the disease several
million died with a mortality rate of
around 3 percent I mean it's it's
mind-boggling when you think about that
stuff Yanis pop has told me to watch an
old Bill Gates pee
and I did today which was terrifying
where Bill Gates kind of really called
this whole whole thing so accurately
that a lot of the people in the
conspiracy side of Twitter elected he
planned this I think like Cedric the
Entertainer reposted a video on
Instagram where he's like well Bill
Gates planned this [ __ ] and then like DL
Hughley was like hmm maybe he did and
then you know there's some other comic
Gary Owen was like the wise a white
Durbin comic I think they were all like
they were all kind of pumping that idea
who knows I don't know
I think Gates probably called it out
pretty pretty accurately but they don't
none of them care this is the problem is
like everybody talks everybody says how
you know we got to prepare we're not
prepared were woefully underprepared and
then nobody prepares nobody cares it all
goes back to it's a selfish country
where if you're not being affected I
mean dude we watched you when you think
about it we watch this unfold in China
for like over a month yeah and did
nothing since like early January I mean
Trump put a travel ban on China great
but he didn't get more tests here hmm
like Google's building a website now to
test people or or you know to help help
them realize if they have symptoms or
not but that could have been done oh and
I mean listen it's that Trump's fault
the coronavirus but it does unmask a
little bit you know where Trump is weak
and he's weak and a pandemic he's not
the president you really wanted a
pandemic you want somebody that is a
little bit more cerebral in a pandemic
you go to bed a little easier with an
Obama type in office then you do with
Trump Trump's great when the economy's
roaring you know but when uh you know
when you're and and what's weird about
this cuz one of our other friends call
me and said um you Becky is like you've
been through 9/11 you've been through
other things how does this differ you
know and I was like well in those
periods of time
you saw a lot of compassion and empathy
human compassion empathy now because
everybody's terrified of getting sick
you don't see any of that people are
terrified of each other
somebody coughing makes them an enemy so
people are looking out for themselves
and their families in there's a dearth
of compassion togetherness just being
outside being with other people people
are cut off from each other in in a real
meaningful way that you know you didn't
see during 9/11 they had the candlelight
vigils and hand-holding and the people
coming out and 9/11 was scary for a
bunch of other reasons people that what
the [ __ ] you know people who seeing Jets
rip up the sky going like what's coming
next as SARS it's an anthrax there's
that bio you know every news week every
different cover was like is it sarin gas
what's coming what's the threat level is
it burnt sienna what does that mean um
but you could go outside you could talk
to people you could go out with your
friends you eventually could go to movie
theaters and shows and concert I mean
you could just life went back to normal
we're in the initial stages here of how
how big this disruption is gonna be but
one thing I think that people can't
fully appreciate is the end-times feel
of a society that where everybody's cut
off from each other because it truly
does feel like we're heading into this
uncharted territory and we don't you
like you know how we deal with this in
mentally emotionally these are all real
questions you know how is this going to
affect people when they're cut off when
they can't work when they can't go out
when they can't exercise in the way that
they want when they when they have to
just stay home how many marriages are
gonna fail because husbands and wives
are gonna have to talk to each other you
know I mean it's gonna be a little crazy
all schools are they're letting them out
so now there's kids everywhere I'm power
[ __ ] some of them are still working
like what am I gonna do there's gonna be
roving bands of tic toc errs prowling
around they're all immune all these
little [ __ ] tick tock [ __ ] are
immune they're not getting this it's not
affecting them so they're gonna be going
out playing with dead bodies you thought
what Logan Paul did was bad what about
that times a trillion go look at the
statistics these little kids are gonna
be doing Michael Jackson [ __ ] what's
that thing he done what's the Thriller
videos with real bodies I'm telling you
it's gonna happen these little
narcissist go on that app they don't
even blink these tick tock fox they're
craving bitter little monsters and that
bitter for any real reason just their
acidic toxic little human beings black
pill they grew up believing in nothing
they care about nothing except except
likes and followers and views and money
merch they believe in nothing they're
perfectly suited for this environment
they're gonna play with dead boomer
bodies and dance around the streets
they're gonna dance around as the bodies
burn and you're gonna learn to fear
those little bastards you're gonna learn
to feel those little tick-tock Fox
running around with their phones
documenting their brutality little gangs
of tick stalkers documenting what they
do to the bodies and you'll be sitting
in your houses terrified watching the TV
it's gonna be rough folks that's at
least what I see happening I could be
wrong but again am I ever have I ever
been you're gonna see very soon just
bodies little tick stalkers using real
bodies like marionettes it's some of it
will be artful
some of it will be interesting visually
appealing and stimulating and you might
say oh this isn't that bad but their
bodies these are just my thoughts
unfiltered you know these are just the
things that I think about the things
that need to be said but nobody else is
saying and it's gonna be we're gonna
have problems we're gonna have a lot of
problems but if you're locked up you're
gonna need to have sex and you're gonna
need to have it with a nice blue shaved
penis or vagina or penis that's been
made out of clitoris which they can do
okay don't debate me at all this it's
not as important remember when the
problem was to drag queens in the
libraries yeah that was fun remember
when that was a big moral issue with a
drag queen should we read to kids now
it's like everybody's everybody's gonna
die the engineers at manscaped have
spent the last 18 months creating the
perfect ball hair trimmer man they
should have been working on a vaccine
and they've just released a new and
improved lawn mower 3.0 smooth out your
scrotum with new ceramic blade a
manscaped advanced skin safe technology
let's see if the ads change at all as we
head into the apocalypse like if they
change the ads you know at all like hey
spending a lot of time inside ahaha
well don't worry because man escapes got
you covered
don't worry eventually the military will
leave your street you'll be allowed to
go outside but right now just shave it
there's a lot of fancy copywriting that
means it won't Nick you were snag your
nutsack that's what skin-safe technology
is you got to shave your balls it's the
best razor system you've ever owned it
features an LED light so you can get
into all those nooks and crannies I
don't know why how that helps but
whatever they've also juiced this baby
with 7000 rpm motor that's what you want
knew your [ __ ] is a nice big motor the
battery now lasts up to 90 minutes you
could shave your dick for 90 minutes and
you're gonna have the time because the
economy's collapsed so this is just
great ways to to fill up your day now
that you don't have a job and you can't
go outside because you're gonna be
killed by roving
to take soccers that are immune to the
plague the battery now lasts up to 90
minutes and the charging stand is
powered by USB this couldn't be safer to
use get 2000 it's ray cop is calling us
should we answer it let's connect the
Bluetooth real quick hold on let's
connect the Bluetooth okay turn your
Bluetooth on we'll call him right back
hold on get 20% off free shipping when
you use the code Tim in manscape calm
that's manscape calm and use a promo
code t IM for 20% off your first order
he's got nothing to lose folks 20% off
free shipping manscaped ma n s CA PE d
comm promo code Tim you need this you
need it and you're good at we're gonna
use a road caster yeah so I'm gonna go
on bluetooth my bluetooth is on Road
caster probably connected to that it
says connected now all I have to do is
call him Ryan call Raymond we're gonna
call ray back now he's in New York
Roseanne is also gonna be on the show I
didn't want I wouldn't want to I don't
want to tease you but we got big things
coming up here this is what we're really
gonna shine in the quarantine and we're
gonna keep doing the show until we can
legally not do it then I have to call
Ben on FaceTime and then he'll upload I
mean we'll just we're gonna keep getting
it out folks right what did that fat
[ __ ] do we hate is found well way from
the callback but my point here is this
we're gonna keep this show going full
steam ahead we got a lot of people
coming up we did a nice little Corona
special we had dr. Steve from ona he
answered some questions we had my
friends heartless fiance I call who's a
nurse who was like this will help with
social security because all the old
people are gonna die everybody was like
oh my god but that's that nurses and
flight attendants don't see any value in
human life they don't care nurses he
death every day and flight attendants
have made peace with their own death and
the death of everyone on that vehicle
flight attendants are sick have you ever
looked in the eyes of a flight attendant
SiC they get up on Southwest to do a
little comedy routine hey that's a sick
job for sick people to be up there at
that altitude and not give a [ __ ] you
freak
drinking tomato juice and pineapple
juice at 35,000 feet getting whipped
around by the hand of God you're defying
God every time that plane takes off you
monster
they don't care flight attendants and
they know it I knew a few flight
attendants drug addicts straight-up drug
they are so peeled up they don't even
know they're on a plane these [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and then a lot of gay guys do the flight
attendant job to it's just they just
[ __ ] and do drugs and they all want that
plane to crash they hate landing they
love taking off because there's a chance
to play in a limo liate in the air they
hate landing
they're all [ __ ] chunked up druggies
anyway that's neither here nor there
we're in the midst of a plague this is a
sinus infection I have I don't think
it's Corona I don't have a fever I can
and I've been coughing for like a month
you would have it by now yeah other
people that have been around me would
have it I've just been coughing because
I went to Toronto and I was smoking
cigarettes and I just kind of in then I
had strep throat and that [ __ ] me up
so I'm just trying to like I'm not
smoking cigs and I die I will smoke
occasionally I have not smoked cigs in
like a month or three weeks I'm not
gonna smoke them anymore
we need our lung capacity now so I'm not
smoking cigarettes I just I need to
build a lung capacity lungs because this
is a disease of the lungs if you get it
and it gets bad you feel like you're
drowning in there it's not good nobody
wants it you got to stop the weed too I
know a lot of you switch to edibles stop
smoking the weed I mean it's you know or
don't switch to edibles and get off
drugs be a person start thinking about
what's important like supporting this
goddamn show and your family in that
order
because we're gonna have a lot of
problems here are they quarantining all
of us let's try ray one more time what
the [ __ ] just happened you think you
just called me right before just passed
out in Ag in a corona haze does he butt
dial a lot not really
now I'm only hearing him in one ear I
wonder if he's been quarantined like
he's been put in he's being like dragged
away listen to me
Robert Howard self isolating that put me
in this are you a general I want to be
taken away by general not the National
Guard is his his um his thing is so nice
is the colostrum and to come I can't
come to the phone and then you see him
like what his real message should be if
his message looked sounded the way he
looked it would just be this just he's
in the throes of some nightmare
considering a total complete shutdown
how many cases in Seattle and Portland
that's another hot spot the Pacific
Northwest is a big hot spot for this
[ __ ] came out of a nursing facility a
nursing home up there it's a real issue
everybody's getting those texts and
you're the next to be quarantine
everybody's like I don't want to alarm
you but I don't want to alarm you but I
will let you know that my sister works
for the CDC and she said that tomorrow
they're putting a dome over Portland you
know this is this is what everybody's
saying I don't want to alarm anybody but
I have a highly placed source in the
government that says that tomorrow
morning at 9 o'clock the military is
gonna come into your house and [ __ ] you
and your ass in front of everyone you
know and upload it and put it on the
internet I don't want to alarm anybody I
don't want to alarm you hey I don't want
to alarm anybody but I have a source
right now that says that the government
has decided to nuke Portland don't want
to alarm and
one that's happening tomorrow around
3:00 what does it say Seattle and King
County
yeah they got hit hard I got hit hard
fifty eight new cases today yeah five
deaths problema county total is now 32
deaths and 328 total cases this is why
we're trying to cut you got a curb it
you got a curb this thing you got a curb
the transmission of this virus if you
can by not going out you can't go out
you can't talk to your friend you got to
stop with the drinks after work cut it
out maybe it is maybe the virus is fake
and maybe they're using this as a way to
Institute martial law but let's help
them I'm kidding the virus is not fake I
mean you can't look at Italy and say
this is fake you can't look at your eye
and say this is fake now I don't know
where the [ __ ] it came from maybe
there's a bio weapon maybe it's not I
don't know it's you know at this point
does it matter just get the [ __ ] off
stage and stop you don't have to talk
about your dick in front of a roomful of
300 people you can wait that can wait
people are sick
this thing's a nasty [ __ ] bug dude
it's a nasty [ __ ] bug and it's coming
coming for a lot of people Seattle's
[ __ ] yeah New York is [ __ ] - check
la what's california god okay i think
we're doing kind of okay here I think
we're doing okay I could be wrong
six deaths 247 cases currently in Los
Angeles Los Angeles County yeah it's a
big County but that's still ain't great
300 cases confirmed cases in LA six
deaths the majority of these are gonna
be older people that being said some of
them would be you know autoimmune people
that have you know they're compromised
that have underlying conditions but you
know who knows we've got a lot of risk
factors in the country fat people
smokers I don't know we got 40 in LA 40
cases in Los Angeles yeah
but you know there's so much more dude
yeah dude there's so much more what do
you think it really is 4,000 probably 10
times what they think right it has to if
I got it I would just stay inside I want
to go to a hospital well that's what
they're telling people to do they like
don't go to a hospital and you're like
why they're like cuz this is fake yeah
they keep saying they're like why can I
not go to a hospital they go cuz this is
faith this is pretend this is just a way
to yeah soon we're gonna be broadcasting
you're gonna see a butt of a gun pressed
in my head and the military's gonna be
behind us and the military's gonna read
ads for Ridge wallet wouldn't that be
great generals just handing me ads for
Ridge wallet and I'm like Hello Colonel
has a Ridge wallet don't you remember
when it was just that the country was
run by satanic pedophiles those were
just good old days those were the good
old days a corrupt oligarchy of
politicians who murder in blackmail each
other while they steal the resources
pillage destroy the planet but you still
got to go to Disney World and TGI
Fridays now you can't even do that you
can't have a three for all which is
mozzarella sticks buffalo wings potato
skins can't even do that anymore
everyone's gonna become a [ __ ]
conspiracy head I can't wait till
everybody starts discovering Reddit and
4chan what if the whole country goes
unfortunate what if the whole country
goes on reddit what if the entire
country just [ __ ] goes off the
[ __ ] deep and gets [ __ ] red pills
and starts going crazy I mean it could
happen some of them are there some of
them are gonna go down the Batchelor
wormhole or whatever so lots of there's
lots of places online you can reside I
don't think it's healthy to spend all
your time reading about the demons that
run the show but you do have to peek
behind the curtain take a look at the
demon every now and then we weren't CBS
today and it's a very cavalier attitude
nobody's got masks on and the
pharmacists we are so one mask the
majority of them do not have masks
mm-hmm no gloves it seems pretty lacks
now you wonder if in a week or two
that's gonna be like oh boy I can't
believe can't believe we were [ __ ]
that lakhs right it might be I don't
know but I mean I could also tell you
this you know we all got to keep our
wits about us folks because we're gonna
get over this we're gonna get through
this okay
I'm gonna tell you right now we're gonna
we're gonna get through it and I know
that a lot of people didn't feel
comfortable because Trump looks like he
kind of has it but he's looks puffy and
sniffly you know but I will say to all
of you out there we're gonna get through
it
we're gonna get through it and then
we're gonna be as selfish and as
unprepared as we were for this don't
worry don't worry don't worry tick-tock
errs when you grow up and you're
pandemic its we will have done nothing
to prepare trust me
I'm telling you right now I mean maybe
I'm wrong but we're gonna get through it
we're gonna fight through it we're gonna
get through it the way we we get through
everything in this country by sitting on
our fat ass isn't eating we're gonna get
through it the way we get through
everything by not leaving our homes and
watching streaming services and putting
things in our mouths that's how we're
gonna get through it don't worry about
it
don't give it a second thought if
there's one thing that people in this
country can do it they can sit on their
couch Goddard do I have faith in this
population of people Raymond you're on
the podcast you called in the middle of
us recording hello Raymond he should be
character now yes you're on the podcast
you called in the middle of us recording
well you called me hello everybody how
are you you called me first I called you
back twice oh I am [ __ ] I'll jump
forever anyway it's great to be on the
show
what's going on if we [ __ ] but it
what a sweet sweetheart update us from
New York you're our point you're our
connection in New York what's going on a
lot of hoarding going on
I mean you going to these stores it's
[ __ ] the showings are pretty bare
I got toilet paper I don't know what
they're talking about I got plenty of
toilet paper it's definitely taken yeah
but other stuff you know corn rice
things like that you know quinoa it's
definitely uh you try getting like
[ __ ] whole food take like a week now
you and your lover have a footy of a
50-pound bag of rice you said I got a
twenty pound oh wait let me check what
the [ __ ] right now do you deal with a 20
pound bag of rice I mean look you open
it up and you because your mouths into
it you know you chew it
no I didn't in case in the disruption oh
no I'm just I'm prepared right I love
that you were you were [ __ ] on
everybody last week for preparing now
you're getting bags of rice right on the
ground of change are they gonna be able
to keep everyone in their house if they
do a nationwide lockdown quarantine that
thing aren't there too many people too
many guns I mean do you think it's a
quarantine that I don't know you you
might know better than me you might not
does a quarantine mean everyone has to
stay in their house
what does it mean you just can't leave
it like can you take a walk what's the
deal well I'm not sure what
terminologies why I think in Italy right
now they can't eat right yeah that's all
there is that video of it all playing
the tarantella or whatever like you know
calm each other down yeah they're on
they're on the porch they're on their
balconies banging tambourines well I
mean in New York City
the NYPD or just you know I think a
[ __ ] nice things just you know if I
get out of line but uh you know
the country I mean it's not as you know
if you live in some rural area where
like your camera clicking like house I
mean it's not as big a deal if you need
to have and whatever further will they
will lock every wound a little bit a lot
people down in the areas where badges
probably right yeah I mean using people
going like that you're shooting their
way out of the block
who knows dude you know this country who
knows there's a sizable amount of people
on Twitter who think that you know this
is a cover for Trump is gonna go arrest
Obama and then all the celebrities for
the pedophile stuff [ __ ] what's his
name people aren't like I'm seeing this
[ __ ] and it's just like there's chewin
on rambling a definition but pointy
queuing on people and [ __ ] there's no
there's no one had an end game no one
has a [ __ ] reason it's just like the
Liberals I mean some random some media
guys later finally yeah big business I
mean you did this serene cancel only
event sweet Harper right a good point
yeah I mean I just [ __ ] I don't I mean
you know me I'm down for a good yeah I
believe I'm like half the I'm like
halfway like the cute on people I'm like
I'm with him halfway there like
everybody empowers a satanic pedophile
I'm like okay and then they're like and
they're all going to jail I'm like now
yeah probably not yeah sadly no I don't
see any I don't see any proof that's
happening but but yeah that was so what
they said is though this is a false flag
or whatever you want to call it so
they're they're you know they're closing
the schools and the sports and all the
arenas so that they can go arrest Obama
and Hillary and that Obama and Hillary
won't launch attacks it's safer that the
elites major in chief if you want arrest
Obama I mean it's bad form but you can
do it but you know me
you have had this talk this is what
happens when your whole life is pretty
mainstream you believe mainstream things
then all of a sudden you get read pilled
overnight your mind melts and then you
you can't cope with the world as it is
and you start concocting stories about
what's [ __ ] really happening people
love me so and Hillary the way these
people see Bill Hillary right it's a
Batman movie realized if I can take it
neurotoxin yeah it's like using your
secret agent right [ __ ] you there
yeah we've had people killed but like I
don't know a thing cuz I'm like [ __ ]
like epic chess match of like [ __ ]
spies going on here it's a bunch of
pedophiles and people who want pipeline
yeah ain't that sexy folks I mean why
would why don't they face it out right I
think it's a crock good point
well I'll tell you why this is do you
want to know the answer because I read
it on Twitter they did it someone from
chase told this guy on Twitter that
we're in a transitional economy trump's
trying to get rid of the Fed so they
have to tank the economy in order to
rebuild the new economy without a Fed I
don't think they know right yeah I mean
I'm not saying it but I mean I don't I
think Trump is crazy because they got
badges they were like raisins race like
a 1/4 of a baker point but you know but
most these presidents I mean they don't
do everything that [ __ ] runs on
Morgan's anymore well listen you asked a
question and you got an answer why were
they tenth because they always have an
answer and the answer is one of nine
possibilities and that's the answer and
they've gone from the virus they people
people are [ __ ] is weirding leftist
or the one but rightfully delicious or
like I'm weakening
you like to [ __ ] eat food Robin tax
incentive [ __ ] supposedly and adderal
just freaking advocate something you
know are getting off on your face man
but uh but here is a repeating at the
end of monetary policy that's like I
don't under they really think there's
more to they really think there's that
people like people don't know what
they're doing Ben Bernanke barely knew
what he was doing at all yeah people are
just riding but it's either [ __ ]
that's what it's so hard for people to
understand that the people at the top
it's not necessarily like this
well-orchestrated thing it's actually
just [ __ ] like you know hold on to
your hat we're just going we don't know
what's gonna happen and let's just
[ __ ] cover our tracks as we go yeah I
mean but in Norway happiness we're like
we don't want you to die thank you US
economy after like for a hundred years
like I mean like yeah you don't want
politics aside you don't want to be the
[ __ ] [ __ ] just drop the ball I mean
no Trump seems to be a little immune to
that he really seems I mean now he's
getting their mother-in-law baby but but
he doesn't seem to give a [ __ ] about
like you know I don't think people fully
understand the level of indifference and
I think that is what bothers people it's
like that you know there's a great line
from a song you know it's a better you
know John Gorka as if folks here he goes
you know it's not hatred there's no hate
from her the facts of indifference are
cruel and it's like I don't think people
truly comprehend that these people don't
care they're sociopaths
it isn't this well-planned you know 3d
chess thing it's people that are just
trying to as russ Baker said preserve
themselves at all costs yeah they're
just trying to preserve their self
the only thing acting unusual about
troubles before it's like he did not
like 11 billion but he probably has a
couple billion right there all right
it's like and only fans knew I believe
[ __ ] making money at bar-ilan Alisha
but why should a tune of tens of million
maybe even a hundred play interest or
like what crazy is that like when you
already have a few billion you're gonna
like I'm not saying you care that much
about the presidency but you care so
little that you'll just ruined your name
for history for like money that really
doesn't mean that much that's the funny
thing about ahead sound that much right
well yeah I wasn't completely broke
there's only paper I don't think it's
completely broke but I also think he
doesn't think he's degrading his name
you know I I mean it's it's like the
George Carlin line when he goes you know
sociopaths a very high self-esteem you
know I don't I tend to believe he thinks
this is the only way to cement his
position in history I mean I don't think
you know he would have gotten into
history the books for The Apprentice
certainly not in the way that he's in
there now but I do think this could be
the end of his political career I mean
this could get her a bad you know people
you know it yeah we might miss the
window we might have missed
I don't want to buy too much into
immediately into like the worst case
scenario but there are a few different
people out there like your scientists
saying like now in containment there's a
we missed that we missed something
am I talking about a million dead
America possibly like yeah yeah I look
great in November or October when you're
running but the guy running against him
is like has full onset dementia Joe
Biden wait you don't think you don't
think it's a good chance I'm not saying
that I think is that there's a even
minor chance maybe that with all this
hysteria people start shifting on birth
I hope so and I mean there's that debate
so I think what Bernie I stood to see
Bernie I think one of the things about
Bernie Bernie kind of lacks this killer
instinct where like Bernie has to leave
Biden on the floor in that debate he has
to leave him on the floor and he has to
you know make them really expose him
for what he is which is kind of like
this mentally [ __ ] you know like he's
incapable of doing this job you know and
I think Bernie yeah he's a team today
another video out of a white background
where he just blabbering yes and like
United patiently member no I'm sorry
speakerphone yeah yeah it's almost like
that like that's is Harry not not the
vibrant like right well it's a perfect
storm now of like everything that could
go wrong it's like you have a pandemic
you have a country as twenty trillion
dollars in debt we have Foreign Wars and
entanglements we have a bloated corrupt
oligarchy and the two people that are
running it are elderly men that both may
be kind of mentally unfit for the job
like there's no new blood nobody's young
nobody's interesting nobody's exciting
every but I mean it's like you want to
talk about the end of an empire it's
like it ends with these elderly
kleptocrats other than Bernie just
trying to steal the rest of this did you
try to loot and you look at Biden son in
the Ukraine it's like kind of hilarious
it like everybody in Washington's kid
works for a Ukrainian natural gas
company I mean it's like it's clearly
just late-stage like let's loot let's
you know it's their version of going
into a grocery store it's a
smash-and-grab and yeah I think Bernie
has to leave them on the floor in that
debate and then this is Bernie's type if
there was ever a time for a guy like
Bernie it's right now like [ __ ] the bed
the [ __ ] really like Biden just comes
restaurant I mean it would be so all
these means I like Bernie I hope I hope
it does take care of that but it would
just be like he hasn't great not great
work Tory sense but me we get going it
didn't usually doesn't really
he doesn't lean in you said the best
thing when I'm like hey I think it's the
beginning of the end of the Trump
presidency because it can't be funny
anymore with the circumstances
you said something brilliant you go
he'll find a way to be funny about dead
bodies remember that you're like he'll
find a way to make the the deaths of
your neighbor funny like that's our
weekend at Bernie's yeah
what a dark thought Trump's roasting the
dead
you know but the next election he's like
that didn't work out too well for those
people hey you didn't vote for me didn't
work out too well for you now you're
burning industry you think there's any
you have any chance he tries to bomb his
way out
what are you gonna bomb see our of
Portland
I'm gonna Bob no I mean I mean the
platform the fact that like you know
October comes oh yeah I understand what
you're saying who knows I mean I don't
know you know there's a lot of people
saying oh oh they'll cancel the election
but it's like here's the deal
it's a [ __ ] it's all unprecedented
you don't know what he's gonna do
I hope to god this is a three-month
saying two to three months I don't think
it will be I think it's gonna be more
like six months by I don't know if it's
six months of being stuck inside but I
think it's six months of disruption you
know her disruption the China is pretty
much China like getting back on track I
mean they had the hotel collapse on
people I mean China gets back on track
they'll just they'll just torch your
city you know they'll just torch your
city and be like back to business
you know I mean read too hard that have
you no no nothing is not better no but
no but we're sentimentalist so we're
gonna have like a bunch of vigils is
gonna be coronavirus to musical you know
it's it's gonna be a different process
than china who's just like okay that's
done
next you know break up yeah well one
more question
what do you have to say
I'm saying like dick verse 911 is
definitely a bigger scope to it yes I
don't think it does I'll tell you no 911
you could see human compassion and
empathy now people are scared of each
other when you when someone coughs they
become your enemy that does a lot it's
isolating it's lonely in 911 in that
time you had these vigils you have
people going out you're people
connecting with other people
we're eliminating that now and I'm
telling you right now it's gonna be
[ __ ] quiet to watch people just go on
lot people are spending enough time
online now we're just locking people in
and saying go on the Internet we're
gonna see people go we're gonna see a
lot a large portion of the country will
become schizophrenic in the next 90 days
I mean I don't know a long time you know
you can find me on Twitter Instagram a
tray come do something yes enjoy thanks
he's got a patreon it's called what's
your patreon patreon uh best request
rate um you can go but you got my
Twitter pages on there sadhus Twitter
page folks support and I need to need to
be a patron of the Arts right now and
weird the arts you know thank you right
I'll thank you God bless you and God
bless america well there it is folks
quick little update from New York from
the great Rick comp you know it is
Friday 806 this comes out Saturday you
know Sunday in New York 12:00 a.m. 9:00
p.m. you're on the west coast but it's a
Sunday show so we don't know where we're
at we don't know where we're going we
don't know what's happening we don't
know when and if the quarantines are
coming we're just sitting here waiting
just like you broadcasting into the
night going into the darkness head on
with good spirits high hopes we believe
that we'll get through this
I mean this is just what we do we'll get
through it
we'll sit I'll be a lot of sitting we'll
get through it with some good conspiracy
mongering on every side either side and
they'll be sadly there'll be some death
and there'll be some destruction you
know and they'll be destruction there'll
be disruption they'll be you know
hopefully it's not the end of society
hopefully it's not martial law end times
things like that I don't know hopefully
it's not contagion I mean we watch
contagion the other day that movie sucks
it's not good does these movies are
never that good um but you know on the
flip side of it we are here to provide
you with the analysis we're gonna bring
the experts on Roseanne's coming on
we're bringing on the people that you
need to hear from at this moment we
brought my friends some chick he's
dating as a nurse on brought dr. Steve
from Opie and Anthony the great Rick
comp in New York City giving us updates
he's our New York bureau Chair of our
news service but this is it folks this
is this is the news I am the anchor this
is the news this is the new reality you
might not love it you probably don't
there's negatives to it but let's also
embrace some of the positives you're
gonna get some time now you know
comedies canceled let's enjoy that for a
few weeks
let's enjoy that for a few weeks it's
enjoy Netflix not taping another special
for a little while might be nice I'm
hoping to God that everything gets back
up and running soon so we're all gonna
lose our [ __ ] minds so let's take two
months let's hit this out let's see what
happens we're gonna keep podcasting and
then let's come back on the other end of
this strong go back on the road go back
on tour see what happens I mean two
months is a real [ __ ] pollyannish
lofty aspirational timeline but who
knows maybe maybe it won't be as bad
our people that you know handling this
pretty underwhelmed yeah I mean even at
sprouts last night in Eagle Rock you
were behind Tyler the crater in Bristol
Farms yeah in Eagle Rock at sprouts I
was behind badger from breaking bad so
you can kind of see the class disparity
there yeah with who were were around but
no one really people were just kind of
waltzing around talking on the phone
making jokes about Crona but just
grabbing food no one seems to really
even at CVS did people seem to be that
was how it was in the beginning of Italy
yeah
really people good on just making jokes
cappuccino and now they're just just
banging tambourines on their [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] patios it's a nightmare
so I don't know I don't know which way
we're going but Germany seems okay how
many cases Germany right now
Germany seems like they're doing okay I
don't know ah three thousand six hundred
seventy five cases and eight deaths and
forty six have recovered so far yeah I
mean I don't know 3,000 cases 3,500 case
how many cases in Italy let's go look at
Italy because that seems to be outside
of China I think Italy's the hardest hit
Italy has I mean just this past week
fourteen thousand new cases but they
have seventeen thousand cases so what
does that mean seventeen thousand in
total yeah but like this past week
fourteen thousand new cases yeah yeah so
they are being ravaged and Jesus Christ
I feel horrible that's [ __ ] up yeah
they're being ravaged the country of
Italy is gonna take a while to come back
from this you know yeah if you look at
the map it's all over the country yeah
looks like Milan and everywhere up there
got hit hard Rome only has 215 I wonder
if there were some rich people that got
the [ __ ] out of Italy you know yeah
I wonder if there was anybody who said
let's get out of here I don't know
nobody could nobody knew how bad it was
gonna get right mm-hmm
nobody could know nobody could know
we're all just [ __ ] waiting you know
for the end Tim de la comédie calm no
live dates don't get any tickets to
anything chill out relax buy them it's
not message you mean ask me should I buy
tickets buy them in a month or two
listen buy them when I'm coming don't
buy anything right now I don't know
what's gonna happen nobody [ __ ] knows
what's gonna happen as of right now you
know Philly's cancelled des moines
cancelled
Minnesota's cancelled those are the only
things that are canceled everything's
still on the books right now but I would
not buy tickets right now because I
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on I'm
neither do you and I don't know which
one of you most of these clubs give
refunds some of them will just give you
new tickets I don't know I'd rather not
I'd rather just tell everybody to just
chill the [ __ ] out right now and buy
tickets when we're back up and running I
don't know how long this is gonna be if
you want to support us patreon calm the
tin Dylan show buy this stuff get the
ridge Wallach at the band scape support
the sponsors on the show it's great way
to support the show patreon you get one
extra episode every single week we're
gonna start live streaming to YouTube
that's going to come very soon we're
gonna start putting together more more
and more different types of corona
specials we got Roseanne coming up I'm a
huge fan of her love her we got a lot of
people that are going to come up on the
program so again you know our live
podcast it may is sold out with Ray
comprar a preliminary think it's Matt
early may hopefully that happens let's
see
but you know Tim Jay Dylan TI ll went on
Instagram and Twitter
get on there subscribe to the Tim Dillon
show on YouTube if you can Whitaker who
you are you could be a Q&R hat
you're welcome here mm-hmm you know you
know we don't we know we don't think
you're right you're right about
something's not about others you could
be a violent communist you're welcome
here
we welcome everyone Isis get in here
you're not everybody needs content
everybody needs content because that's
all we have left
get a podcast or a little bit up we're
in the darkness now goodbye